Bram
Knights of Sidonia The
latest 2-part work currently being broadcast Daisetsugumi's painting We
deliver a digest of the world view and story of the work that you can understand even now
[Music]
The people who live at the top when starting to chase the guarantee are
called tents.  He was
living on top of a curtain.
When he started up, the
stars were dotted with
gigantic trees.
[Music]
A boy living in a tent village. The
painting
dreamed that there might be people living under the tent.
[Music]  At
first glance, the village seems to be peaceful,
but the water flowing from the orbital trees that has begun to wither is
running low, and the village is
on the decline.The culture of passing on letters has also declined, and only the
knowledge of reading signboards has been passed down.
What was it for? It
was an important thing.
Meanwhile,
at the foot of the snow group at the time of startup, Riha, the
princess of Atland, the land of the Great Snow Group, was
searching for a wise man who was said to be in a tent above the orbital tree, and was
chasing her through the air.
However,  Just one step away from getting up to the tent,
ships from the enemy country Bargia are approaching. The
escort soldiers are defeated one after another in the attack. Excuse me, it's
dangerous. Thanks
to Jalji's life-threatening defense, Riri-nami
was able to escape into the sky just in the nick of time.
[Music]
[Music] It
carries Liliha and ascends towards the tent, floating.
And it finally reaches the tent.
[Music]
Liliha climbs up to the tent, loses consciousness, and is
rescued by a painting. For the
first time.  A painting in which I am confused by the young woman I see
[Music] I am
Kaina-
sama I thought I had finally found the sage I was looking for, but for a
brief moment the
world of the tent was told like a fairy tale.But the
sage Liliha was looking for was not there.  That's right.
[Music] It was
n't a dream. It really happened. The
world of the tent. I
talked about the world I was in. It
must have been a shock to Kaina and the others, who thought there were no people outside of the tent village.
Furthermore,
[Music]
Surprisingly, in the world, there are
wars between countries over scarce water.
Countries with powerful wars have begun stealing water from neighboring countries one after another. They have been
deprived of water.  I heard that the country was in ruins, and even those who survived
became slaves.When I was a child, my
mother often
searched for something that had a mysterious power.She said that a
wise man could produce an infinite amount of water.  The
conflict will end, but there is no sage in the tent,
and Lily Wave is told by the village in the tent that there
is no way to return to the Yuki-gumi world.However,
Signboard G has prepared something that he
will use.This
is
[applause]  ]
[Music] It's
very hard.
I don't know what it's made of, but it's a particularly
strong thing. It's
called a bark
scraper. It's an important carpenter's tool that has been passed down from generation to generation. If you
scrape the bark with this, you can
make a hook for a rope. You're on your way, too.  You're the
only one who can guide me.
I'll
accompany you to send you off safely. A
harsh journey towards the world of the Snow Troupe
[Music]
Overcoming the difficulties of Ikuta and steadily
approaching the Snow Troupe
Pleasure and Lilia It's okay, it's
okay, hurry up
Artland  I have to go home.
[Applause] I
have two winter bags, so I'll give you one.
If I don't have this floating lucky bag, if I
fall into the sea of ​​snow, I'll sink.
[Music] You're back,
Lili. The
two of you have finally arrived.  What
happened? However,
in the snow group, Bargia's soldiers were ambushed.
Atlanta's soldiers, led by Kageno, also rushed there, and a
mission to rescue Liliha was carried out. They
absorbed the enemy fleet, attacked, and
fought without knowing why they were escaping.  Painting gets
caught up in this and takes a
desperate action to protect Liliha.
Cage is overwhelmed by the power of Aberoth
[Music]
Liliha is captured by Bargia and she
arrives in Atland disappointed It
was a painting, but
Liliha's father, King Hareku of Adland, was surprised by the number of people seeing it for the first time.
will give up on rescuing her daughter.
[Music]
Liliha's younger brother Yaona appears in front of the painting, which is wondering how to rescue Liliha.
I am Liliha's younger brother. It's true that I came from Lilia's younger brother's tent. It's a
painting, isn't it?
I'm sorry I can't help Liliha, so I
'll go with you.I want to help.The two of us, who share the same feelings, head towards Liliha through a secret loophole.Let's go.Is
Liliha safe?And there's a conflict over the lack of water in
Atland.  And what will be the fate of Bargia?
Will Kaina, the boy who came from the sky, change the world that has been submerged by the Snow Troupe?
Please watch Kaina and Liliha's epic adventure to the end.
[Music]